[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma été pour une fois je
crois que je vais pas vous demander ce
que nous allons faire parce que j'ai
deviné où je crois deviner avec ce que
nous avons sous les yeux nous allons
faire des foies de canard
voilà des bons foie gras des bon foie
gras de canard
ceux là sont particulièrement superbe
ils sont gros ils sont beaux arts de 850
900 grammes 850 900 grammes c'est à dire
que c'est presque le maximum de ce qu'on
peut avoir non plus j'ai un côté plus
gros rien c'est pas rien fournir dans
les jambes pour trouver sa robe ici
surtout s'ouvrir
alors qu'est ce que vous allez nous
faire avec les forts et bien on va faire
des terrines de foie gras l'armagnac des
terrils de foie gras au champagne
terrine de foie gras au point vauvert
cas pourquoi ce que tous ses fruits il
est une nouveauté a et b ça c'est pour
les fugitifs or les fruits qui veut
voilà les gens qui aiment les fruits eh
bien on va leur faire des fruits des
rebelles que je veux calendrier
incertain tôt je ne vous croyais pas
tellement habitués à fréquenter ce genre
de journée végétariens et les fruits et
sports et la recharge
non non non mais je suis pas
végétarienne avait jamais tout mon truc
totalement votre météo régime un petit
peu de coin oui ça fait pas beaucoup
mais ça m'arrive
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
avec tous ces jolis fruits bons lancers
rezéen les mettez pas dans l'info pour
devenir des fois et parce que les il
faut déplacer pour la télé ils ont voulu
dire où je vis des rouges
mais il est faux blanc balaire de notre
part ce sont bien des raisins et
l'émerveillement au réseau ter bon mais
des pommes vous lui avez pour nous dans
le feu des pommes oui des fois oui
des kiwis aussi des kiwis mais que vous
êtes moderne où on a beaucoup de kiwis
dans les landes c'est pas possible
beaucoup de filles oui avec les femmes
passeraient pas croire que vous les
faites pousser parce que ça c'est pas
vrai si vous faites pousser d'ici les
dents et lanières beaucoup des kiwis
année dans la salle ans il ya des kiwis
partout et le meur de changements
étaient là ils sont très bons alors par
quoi allons nous commencer
eh bien on va commencer par les terry de
deux fois est-ce difficile mais pas du
tout c'est enfantin comme on dit chez
nous je peux pas vous croire mais vous
allez voir on va centrer mois et bien
affaire sert tout de suite d'avant il
faut descendre et poivrez alors non on
va commencer par faire la vie de
laquelle lorsque vous allez rire mais de
toute façon il faut laisser les pauvres
tout
alors on prend deux fois j'enlève voilà
le film ira quévert
hiver ça donne de l'amertume parce qu'il
est enlevé le fiel et faut pas rêver on
dit quelquefois qu'il faut les d'énerver
en fait la nationale ou pas oui il faut
savoir le faire et dont il faut savoir
le faire et de deux quintes le foie et
biens de qualité comme ça c'est pas la
peine
au moins pour faire ce qu'on veut en
faire la wii la voilà mais vous savez
pas mal je trouve
et il ya l'épaisseur et même le milieu
je le fais rien oui oui ne pas scorer
très beau très gros il faut qu'ils
prennent et un peu fade ci n'est pas
très bien salé poivré là alors je
répandre une terrine oui celle-là par
exemple oui j'y mets mon fois dedans
alors là il faut pas faire comme je fais
là maintenant il faut le salé le poing
levé au moins 4 5 heures avant de
l'utiliser
et maintenant on ne peut pas le faire
alors on va le prendre comme ça je vais
prendre l'armagnac
je voulais pas la peinture luc
d'armagnac
non je vais pas le mettre sur le dessus
parce que si vous avez saler poivrer
votre foi à l'avance vous faites couler
l'armagnac sur le dessous de la veille
et la canicule à six mois je le fais là
il est tout l'aveyron fois oui après si
vous achetez le gouvernent terrine avec
un couvercle éviter de le mettre parce
que le foie est trop long à cuire de
dames et encore si vous le laissez pas
longtemps à la chaleur il va fondre
tandis qu'avec du papier qu'on ne se
suit vous le mettez à préaubert mari oui
là alors métro auber mari après très
bien oui on va le ballon n'est pas cadré
une seconde tout de suite cela même
cuisson c'est le même poids alors là je
vais seul un accord pour avoir ça vous
savez sûr c'est toujours pareil oui mais
c'est bien de vouloir faire parce qu'on
voit combien il en faut mais il faut
suivre une épaisseur mais n'allez pas
trop vite pour qu'on voit bien alors il
faut sort du sol comme on commence à le
poulet comment sonne
oui voilà vous faites glisser le sait le
poids
après la entre tous les deux entre les
deux labradors
la très bien alors voir celui là et fait
aussi alors même opération je vais le
mettre dans cette terrine oui là et
celui là ouvre à la fois au champagne
alors la toux grasse oui je vous l'avais
dit compter que vous n'arrivez pas
décantée bc peut pas faire la pub parce
que pour nous reprocher on n'est pas
fait pour nous et dans les journaux
alors là pas de jaloux oui c'est un
embarras si vous mettez des bords
champagne demi-secs pas des brutes
surtout surtout parce que ce serait très
acide
alors là m'étais endormi voilà même
opération
on prend le papier et on le couvre je
n'aimerais pas qu'il faut pas brouiller
avec des terrines avait le couvert de la
série découvrez leclerc voilà et là on a
notre troisième petit larron je vous
envie pour que vous ayez la planète ont
besoin dans le mélange sur l'enceinte
est rien la fin est celui là il est un
peu plus petit on va le faire au poivre
vert alors le poivre vert éviter d'y
mettre le jus alors le poids au vert
c'est un pouvoir que vous achetez
liquide et au vinaigre
le pauvre vers ce n'est pas du poivre
que vous achetez sec
voilà la différence le poivre sec et le
poivre vert il est une heure voire vous
avez mis assez généreusement civile
il faut parce que bon alors matériaux
fournis vers le muret du tour et parce
qu'elle confond dans le foie il va se
faire son petit jus et après je vous
apprendrai l'infini tant que ce sera
pareil au bain-marie tout ceci à bari
tout montrer ce que c'est vous allez me
demander de l'eau de l'eau alors je mets
mon plat et je met de l'eau voyons merci
là et au four très chaud et vous allez
le maître ça si c'est un poids de 500
grammes vous allez mettre demi-heure
ample minutes
si sept emplois un fou à l'aube de
séduire 32 30 minutes et l'autre 45
minutes
il est beaucoup plus gros alors celui-là
on le fera cuire après non non ça serait
bien pour la santé va très bien chacun
son tour et voilà à four très chaud 45
minutes un poids de 850 à 900 grammes
bon à tout à l'heure
pendant ce temps nous pourrions faire
les foie poêlé aux fruits met tout de
suite en partant toujours lui
en escale oui j'ai mis les trois poils
qui parle quand vous faites une escalope
lé pa finn si on est mince et il voulait
l'escalope effet après pour le froid ça
c'est pour le faut comme ça c'est pour
le foie avec la poire et ça c'est pour
le fou avec le kiwi les poils étaient
très chaudes et sèches ah oui là voilà
ensuite vous allez me demander
l'ap a d'ailleurs avoir eu le feu et
fruits alors la pomme pour commencer la
pomme
voilà je vous donne françois vergniolle
la forme on la met à courir en lamelles
il faut que ce soit puis en même temps
que le foie et le x va très vite et le
foie furent très vite en même temps que
la pomme tout va se tenir en même temps
ça suffit vous ne croyez pas pour les
femmes la wii en asie puis je vous passe
quoi garnir l'armoire mois la loire
pareil vous enlevez le trognon les
pépins bien entendu et l'esc alors
sortez regarder je fais désormais de
très fines oui pareil
pareil avec une demi heure après les
kiwis alors je vais vous les pattes et
sa micro bic nollet qui vit bien
or il s'avère à caraméliser très vite
voilà mes neveux et le plus petit que ça
va mettre le feu et comme vous voulez
faire la peine de monter leur donnant
chabat c'est bon c'est bon
thomas seydoux de côté en tout cas sera
vite je sais pas si ça sera bon mais je
ligne après bien sûr que ce rebond la
météo il faut ajouter autre chose
entendue
la voilà alors je vais tourner mon poids
1 aux pommes pour les jeunes bien sûr
qui permet l'art aux poires et kiwis
très bien je vais leur salle et et les
liquides maintenant le fort taux le
sauternes
nous allons voir alors le porto pour
commencer les pommes pas mal à vous
qu'on était quand même une bonne
quantité est là alors le porto pour que
tout soit aujourd'hui il doit s'allumer
voilà alors maintenant je sortais je
faisais bien lui les poires il ne brûle
pas au moins là voilà un petit peu et
qu'est ce que vous allez vraiment des
pour les kiwis d'armagnac et s'est très
vite se prouve pour le kiwi
c'est un peu trop tôt soit un peu trop
tôt regardez ça c'est ça qui vient voilà
là et les voilà est-ce que c'est assez
beau voilà sommes pas trop un atout
perry paula et on vole en bout et quand
ces flambées c'est pratiquement puis il
vous croyez que ça sera aussi bon que je
lis bien parce que pour la jolie
ici ce sera aussi bon j'ai pas peur
geneve réalité dans le feu n'est
peut-être pas assez important
ou alors quand vous le ferez que ce joli
frais quand même ça ce ne peut y a plus
qu'à demander à tout instant et ensuite
on n'aura plus qu'à présenter les
flammes et bien sûr et regardez nos fois
qu'il fait nos fous et voilà micheline
toutefois entérine s'en prennent aux
fachos aux fruits sont terminés aussi il
avait préféré manger cet appétissant et
j'ai envie d'aller voir c'est un peu
dans le détail 8 et si vous voulez alors
pour commencer ici nous avons quoi nous
allons le foie en terrine qui se mange
froid fait à l'armagnac
il est superbe et on voit très bien la
différence de couleur avec son voisin
dont le jeu est beaucoup beaucoup plus
est ce qu'ils les fruits aux jeunes par
une celui là il est fait au champagne
oui alors maïté j'ai l'impression que le
champagne est mélangé quand même pas mal
de gran oui mais alors de grâce ce fois
vous donnez vraiment jolie le faux ami
chine bon alors ce x peut se conserver
une semaine au réfrigérateur pas plus
est quand même faut pas exagérer et vous
pouvez même coupé une tranche tous les
jours regroupe une ou deux tranches tous
les jours il ne s'abîmera pas ainsi
qu'ils sont tous pareils tous les trois
pas son pareil là les trois dont nous
répétons bien on y mange froid roi alors
le suivant le troisième il est d'avoir
revers il est délicieux aussi et se
mange pas
couper en tranches un peu tous les jours
si vous le voulez parler manger en
entier et vous le conserver huit jours
pareil vous prenez ça vous à votre petit
déjeuner à vous entendre on croit la
connaître
j'ai ma dose régulière tous les jours et
ça vous profite bien je sais je suis
gâté là dessus alors nous passons aux
foires pour aller se sont présentés dans
les assiettes qui sont encore fumant
voilà alors celui ci c'est quoi ça se
mange frais tout chaud il faut pas
exagérer on le fait et on a marché
bon cela c'est des fois en armagnac aux
kiwis fait d'une nouveauté pascal quiry
relativement récent dans les régions on
en a beaucoup on en a beaucoup dans
notre chalosse à côté à côte et ceux du
foie au sauternes et aux poires ça c'est
délicieux aussi et c'est pareil on a dû
fruits nous en montre région c est enfin
le téléthon c'est le four à chaux
pareille surtout show tous les trois aux
pommes et oporto très traditionnel ce
traditionalisme et délicieux oui alors
certains aux téléspectateurs nous
écrivent nous disent mais les fois c'est
très difficile ça fonce et passifs
offrir beaucoup combien de temps soyez
précis et bien maïté je crois que après
vous avoir regardé précis c'est surtout
dollar c'est à se sentir
il peut être gourmand il faut savoir le
faire il faut aimer le faire voilà
eh bien bon courage à vous essayez bon
appétit et à bientôt
alesha tout
[Musique]